ونشر الجيش السوداني على صفحته في فيسبوك
صورا قال انها توثق عمليات نفذتها قوات
خاصه تابعه لها واوضح الجيش ان قوه العمل
الخاص التابعه له نفذت هذه العمليات في حي
العشره الواقع شرق سلاح المدرعات التابعه
للجيش جنوبيه العاصمه
من الخرطوم انضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي الطاهر اخر التطورات
اخر التطورات عثمان هي اجواء حرب ما تزال
الحرب تخيم على البلاد وما تزال هي تسيطر
على الموقف ويستخدم فيها كل ما هو يعني
قوي من الاسلحه سواء كانت القصف بالطيران
او المدفعيه الثقيله واليوم هذا الصباح
كان هنالك التحليق مكثف للطيران للجيش
السوداني وكذلك المضادات الارضيه لقوات
الدعم السريع حيث قام الجيش بقصف مواقع في
شرق سوبا بالطيران
لاماكن يقول انها هي تتمركز فيها قوات
الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى بالقرب الى
المدينه الرياضيه هذه المدينه الرياضيه
التي ما يزال فيها القصف مستمر ويبدو ان
فيها كثير من المواقع والاشياء التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه سواء كان للجيش السوداني او
حتى بالنسبه للدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه
لان القصف دائما يكون متكرر في هذه
المناطق تحديدا هنا ايضا قصف مدفعي واصوات
انفجارات في مدينه ام درمان واقع متفرقه
الحرب ايضا لا تزال خارج الخرطوم من حين
الى اخر في بعض الولايات وخاصه في مدينه
الاوبيض حيث حلق الطيران التابع للجيش
السوداني سماء المدينه وهنالك قصف مدفعي
في اتجاهات لقوات الدعم السريعه التي يعني
تتمركز في بعض المواقع الغرب والشمال
الابيض في هذه المنطقه في ولايات دارفور
هنالك هدوء في ولايه جنوب كردفان التي
شهدت يعني تصعيد في خلال اليومين الماضيين
حتى الان هنالك هدوء ولكن الهدوء وهدوء
حذر او تكتيكات عسكريه على كل لان ليس
هنالك عهد بين الطرفين لوقف لاطلاق النار
هنالك تصاعد او تفاقم للاوضاع الانسانيه
هنالك انتظار بالنسبه للمنبر الجده خاصه
المفاوضات في جده الحديث والمعلومات تاتي
من هناك تقول ان هنالك مفاوضات غير مباشره
ربما الوسطاء يحاولون يقدمون ايا مقترحات
وان كانت هذه الجوله هنالك تفاؤل بعد ان
رحبت كل الاطراف بهذه الجوله وبالتصريحات
التي وصفت به بالايجابيه سواء كانت من
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بانها ستنجز
يعني وقف اطلاق النار
والنظر في الاوضاع الانسانيه الماساويه
بالنسبه للسوداني
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من الخرطوم